[Musique]
alors puisqu'il faut décidément parler
argent lorsque l'on parle de l'industrie
phonographique j'aurais vous signaler
que justement à cannes au midem le
marché international du disque d'édition
musicale des avocats internationaux se
sont réunis pour essayer de lutter
contre un phénomène qui qui dure déjà
depuis quelques années en amérique en
italie et qui commence en france on sait
pas très bien fait pas faire pour
essayer de le contrer ce phénomène c'est
la piraterie musical qu'est ce que c'est
très exactement que la mise la piraterie
musical et surtout quelles sont les
conséquences économiques de cette
piraterie musicale une enquête d'alain
bereni aujourd'hui encore malgré la
vigilance des organisateurs de concerts
la dernière tournée de dylan en europe
aura aussi des pirates et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est au cours des années 60 que se
situe le boom de la piraterie
quand la technique l'enregistrement sur
bande s'est développé la vente
clandestine d'enregistrement frauduleux
dès cette époque était une source de
profits considérables pour le pirate qui
ne paient ni les cachets des artistes ni
les droits d'auteur encore moins les
taxes et les impôts
la faible qualité de leurs produits
n'avait d'égal que leur faible prix de
vente aujourd'hui avec ses 320 milliards
de centimes de chiffre d'affaires annuel
c'est un véritable cancer économique
tous les artistes à succès sont touchés
dylan presley
les pink floyd mais aussi toscanini la
callas et des centaines d'autres
[Musique]
les plaques tournantes de cette
industrie coupables sont hong kong et
singapour le moyen-orient et les états
unis l'europe est touchée en italie 50 %
du marché du disque est réalisé par les
pirates en france le mal est moindre
mais les principales victimes sociétés
d'auteurs sociétés phonographiques
interprète commence à s'organiser contre
la piraterie
curieusement le terme de pirate est
encore considérée avec sympathie par le
public
la forme actuelle la plus répandue et la
contrefaçon
le produit illégal est présenté sous un
label une étiquette et une image conçu
de telle sorte que ce produit ressemble
exactement aux produits véritables la
contrefaçon malgré son succès n'a
cependant pas éliminer du marché
l'autre importante forme de piraterie
que les américains appellent août les
kings et qui est en fait
l'enregistrement frauduleux d'un
spectacle ou d'une émission de radio
ce terme s'applique généralement à la
commercialisation d'un produit
entièrement nouveau par opposition à une
copie pur et sain
c'est souvent par l'enregistrement à
domicile d'émissions de radio que
commence la chaîne de la piraterie
[Musique]
7h du matin à france musique
kadidia musique philippe caloni bonjour
et tout de suite une avant première
c'est un disque qui n'est pas encore
dans le commerce il s'agit du dernier
enregistrement de la symphonie du
nouveau monde de dvorak par leur caisse
du concertgebouw d'amsterdam dirigé par
coline davis je vous le rappelle c'est
une avant première les immenses progrès
techniques réalisés dans le domaine de
la haute fidélité permettent aujourd'hui
un très large public de posséder des
enregistreurs de cassettes c'est
magnétophone branché sur un
tourne-disque permettent évidemment la
recopie des disques branché sur un poste
de radio
ils permettent à leurs l'enregistrement
d'émissions musicales
ceci n'est certes pas de la piraterie
tant que le particulier vous ou moi ne
commercialise pas cet enregistrement
mais la structure est en place et il
suffit d'avoir quatre ou cinq
magnétophone branché en série pour
pouvoir produire quatre ou cinq copie de
l'enregistrement initial
mieux encore dans des revues
spécialisées
on vous propose pour moins d'un million
de centimes des appareils très
sophistiqués qui autorise un rendement
supérieur de cassettes en moins de
quatre minutes par exemple ces photos
prises par les policiers de hong kong
lors d'une saisie dans un atelier
pirates montrent bien la générosité des
méthodes artisanales des murs entiers de
magnétophone branché en série pour
accroître la production
mais cette ingéniosité est aujourd'hui
dépassé
l'appareil que vous voyez a été saisi il
ya deux mois par les douaniers de hong
kong
à lui seul il effectue le travail de 36
magnétophone fonctionnant en séries avec
un appareil de ce type aient pour un
investissement de 5 millions de centimes
un pirate peut maintenant produire 500
cassettes jour ce rythme de production
semi industriel a fait encore baisser le
prix de revient des cassettes pyrale on
peut estimer en moyenne à 70 % la marge
bénéficiaire des pirates qui rappelons
le fond l'économie de la recherche
artistique des salaires des frais de
commercialisation de publicités et bien
sûr des redevances versées aux auteurs
sans oublier les taxes et les impôts
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y actuellement en france 11 millions
600 mille magnétophone dans quelques
années dix ou vingt ans tout au plus il
y aura sans doute autant de magnétoscope
que de magnétophone et l'on est en droit
de se demander s'il est bien fait
technologique qui nous permette une
radio une télévision les cultures à la
carte
si c'est bien fait ne porte pas en
eux-mêmes le pouvoir de détruire ce
qu'ils devraient propager et si un usage
immodéré des procédés de reproduction la
boue dirais pas rapidement par le
découragement des créateurs des artistes
à un appauvrissement culturel et vigan
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]